foreign
it's a story of poor public policy and
complacency going back
decades it's a story of the inability of
the indian state to show up
when the indian people need it the most
on saturday india saw the world's
highest ever case tally of over 400 000
infections
are we likely to see a peak soon or are
things likely to get worse before they
get better
i don't think from the very beginning
we've ever had an accurate picture of
the virus in india
and we certainly don't have an accurate
picture now
anime
this really was the first tragedy that
i've ever seen
that's played out so close to me on my
social
media feeds people in their own closed
networks of family and friends
crying out for help on their social
media feeds i mean
it can't get any closer than this
india is no stranger to pandemics but
modern india has escaped some of the
worst pandemics the world has seen
for example the previous version of sars
india pretty much escaped that
so it's fair to say that india didn't
really have any competence to deal with
global pandemics of this sort
[Music]
india was one of the first countries to
actually impose a very very strict
nationwide lockdown i remember prime
minister modi came on
television at prime time and said within
four hours the country will be locked
down effectively from midnight
the urgency behind the lockdown left
many people with
a lack of preparation india has a
massive
internal migration waves of people
really flow from the villages
so suddenly when factories were ordered
to be shut
millions of people were rendered
unemployed virtually overnight
then we could see waves of these
internal migrants on roads trudging back
to their villages on foot
they were extremely sad and grim
instances where they were so tired that
they chose to sleep and they were run
down by trains and buses
the predictions were for the worst sort
of carnage in india
however as the as the pandemic kind of
ran through the population
india's mortality rate ended up being
among the lowest in the world
everyone around could see people
affected by the coronavirus
even if they went to hospital they would
get out of hospital relatively soon and
relatively healthy and here we are even
talking about people aged 70 plus 75
80 and older yeah i mean there was a lot
of theories whether
india reached the level of herd immunity
to that point there were other
theories going around like india's a
warm country whether
you know south asian populations were
more genetically
immune or disposed to not feel the worst
effects of covid
but none of them were particularly well
proven
but the official numbers were kind of
showing that there was something going
on anyway
you saw modi at the world economic forum
saying that india had basically
contained the virus and had saved the
world from corona the central bank
itself the reserve bank of india
came out with a really quite
jubilant statement in january saying
that the country had bent
the virus curve like beckham which was
you know obviously a very odd statement
come out for a central bank
but that was the kind of atmosphere at
the time
you had cinemas opening you had you know
the wedding season started and you had
these
mass weddings these huge beautiful
indian weddings with you know hundreds
and hundreds of people
and all of this was done without that
very clear public health
messaging that you need when you're in
the middle of a pandemic it was almost
like
india was an exceptional country that
didn't succumb
to a pandemic that was affecting the
rest of the world
what became clear very quickly was what
we had suspected all along and what many
epidemiologists had been telling us
which is that india had been severely
under counting both its infections
and its deaths we know that many many
many deaths in normal times in
india aren't properly recorded
particularly when you get into the
hinterland which is where 70 percent
of india's population live something
like only 20 to 30
of deaths are properly recorded so the
government engaged in a lot of
grandstanding about how fabulously it
had done
and yet what happened turned out very
differently indeed
[Music]
this really has been the first major
global crisis that's played out
since social media became such a huge
factor in people's lives and
particularly in
india social media has caught on in the
last few years there are
half a billion whatsapp users
but what happened was real crowd-sourced
chaos that was playing out on social
media
there was misinformation about fake
covet
cures immunity boosters herbal
concoctions that could save people from
getting coveted
dab some lemon juice on your nostril and
you'll be safe
yet prevention behavior
the problem is that a lot of people that
use social media
have gotten on to the internet very very
recently so it's really difficult for
them to distinguish
what's fake and what's real facebook
said it had removed
12 million pieces of misinformation
relating to covet globally
you know from its network but you know
that's
really a drop in the ocean considering
how many millions
of misinformation pieces are still
floating around the cyberspace
so a lot of that misinformation has
actually
come back to haunt a lot of indians
during the pandemic
[Music]
the fact is that india has over the
years converted in
itself into a powerhouse of vaccine
creation
in fact more than half of the world's
children are inoculated with a vaccine
developed in india
and therefore this one particular
company the serum institute of india
which is situated just outside mumbai
was seen as
a hope for the world not just india
adar punawala is the head the ceo of the
syrian institute of india
and he's this 40 year old son of a
billionaire
father who founded this company in the
1960s
in mid-2020 punawala signed a deal with
astrazeneca to supply 1
billion doses of its vaccine for the
world and
400 million of those were meant to be
produced by the end of the year now that
didn't really play out as things went
ahead
by january it transpired that only 70
million of those doses had been produced
so far
and in the start of january there wasn't
a huge amount of demand in india because
basically there weren't that many cases
and all the while india's government was
sending tens of millions of doses
out overseas it was engaged in code
vaccine diplomacy it was really trying
to sort of
needle china which was attempting to do
the same at the time as well
india has exported or donated more than
60 million doses of coronavirus vaccines
to countries far poorer than india
it was seen as a massive diplomatic
victory
for india's ruling party little did they
know that
a more potent strain of the virus was at
the same time growing within the people
in india
[Music]
so there were various consequences of
india emerging relatively
unscathed from the first wave one of
those
was the sense to be self-sufficient
[Music]
local manufacturing local
market
[Music]
imposed massive taxes on imported goods
unfortunately some of these goods that
were imported
was stuff that's essential for our
scientist labs to test the virus
the second mistake that was made was the
calling for elections
and not just elections but massive
public rallies
some of them led by prime minister modi
himself
the next round of mistakes that were
made was giving the green light
for massive religious ceremonies a sure
short recipe for a super spreader
the next problem that local authorities
point out is
over centralization of powers within the
prime minister's office
including how oxygen will be shared
between the states
this really has proved to be a game
changer because every time a state fell
short of oxygen it
lacked the powers to go out and get it
for themselves
[Music]
one of the scariest things when the
second wave hit was the fact that
india was running out of oxygen
sometimes this
is working sometimes this other
cylinder is a connection i visited
a private hospital in new delhi where
they didn't know from one day to the
next how much
oxygen they were going to receive when
it would come
and how long it would last and they had
dozens of patients on on oxygen and
relying on that oxygen to stay alive
i get maybe around 50 calls every day
somebody's asking for beds somebody's
asking for cylinders somebody's asking
for drugs
we don't have anything available
and patients are dying now india
produces
more oxygen than it needs the problem is
that most of it is produced in the
eastern part of the country which
lacks supply links to the rest of the
country on a typical day when it's
business as usual in india
hospitals will in place a standing order
but when a situation breaks down the way
it did with the panic
of the second wave supply chains
completely get eradicated
and that is what india saw
what this led to is it led to black
marketing
the hospitals had certain contractual
agreements with oxygen suppliers
but there were always people willing to
pay more for that as a consequence we
are in this terrible humanitarian
disaster really
where people the citizens of india have
had to plead for oxygen on twitter
it was an unprecedented situation really
in india
that so many so-called
privileged people found themselves
suddenly in the same
boat as very average indians all
fighting for that one oxygen
concentrator or that one
last hospital bed that one particular
hospital
had going and it was really a
free-for-all
while people are looking at social media
hoping to find that
lifeline oftentimes social media has
actually
increased the trauma for families of
patients because they
end up calling dozens and dozens of
numbers and then
find that you know they've lost precious
time and and there have been instances
that i know of where patients have
passed away
because the network hasn't quite come
through
the asymmetry i think has been
particularly stark during this crisis
that people who don't have access to the
internet or don't have a smartphone that
they where they can whatsapp somebody to
ask for something
then they've been kind of really left
out of this
whole fight for resources they don't
even get a chance
what we were seeing is people lying in
beds people being
bundled into any possible vehicle that
was available because ambulances were in
short supply
and being taken to hospital for just
that instant hit of oxygen that could
possibly prolong their life
what we saw was heart-rending messages
on whatsapp
where families were telling other
relatives or their friends
my loved one has died which means that
the hospital now has a bed available you
can take it
what we saw was reporters going out on
the field
going out to crematoriums and saying
that the government has told us
40 people died in the city today i am
showing you my camera is showing you
that 500 buyers are burning right now
what we had was crematorium workers
telling us i will go to hell
if i lie to you and tell you that this
is not as bad as it sounds
we went to one of the main crematoriums
on the outskirts of jelly which is on
the banks of the ganges river
there were so many pyres burning the
heat was extraordinary
and of course instead of the normal
morning scenes that you would have
all of the relatives are in full ppe
and no one can hear each other through
the masks and over the sound of the
fires burning
it's traumatic enough to have someone
that you love die but to have to not be
able to save them and to try
so hard to do it is just absolutely
agonizing
so when people started asking for
vaccines urgently
india just did not have the supply to
give them the country of 1.3 billion
people which had so generously donated
vaccines to countries far poorer than
itself earlier
suddenly found that their own population
was effectively naked it it lacked the
protection
that even a single dose of the
coronavirus vaccine could offer
that's a big irony is that you've got
the world's largest vaccine
producing hub but it isn't able to
supply itself let alone the rest of the
world
so many of the poor and middle income
countries that were dependent on
india supplying the kovacs initiative
for instance that's just not going to
happen for a while and they're
really those countries are the ones that
are going to be very hard hit by this
and at the same time you know i think a
lot of western countries have been
criticized for not sharing their
vaccines
particularly of india and and others as
well so you're really seeing this as a
you know kind of part of the picture of
the wider sort of
global inequality that we're seeing
around around vaccines
some of the poorest and the most
vulnerable sections of society
probably lack even the basic health
infrastructure that is a human
requirement it's a basic right but
probably for the first time the
so-called privileged in this country
are facing what the poor indian faces
every day
that not even money can buy you a
hospital bed
and really the second wave of the
coronavirus has exposed
severe cracks in indian society in
indian policy making in india's
healthcare system
that are essential to be filled if we
have to go ahead as a nation
when cases started shooting up and there
were thousands of fatalities
a lot of people on the social on social
media networks
called for prime minister modi's
resignation
and then the next thing you heard was
that the government had asked facebook
and twitter to take down those posts
but there were also instances where
social media networks just
took down these hashtags on their own
and
then came in for huge criticism because
they were acting really out of turn
because
they were actually stifling people's
criticism of the government
and of the prime minister in handling
this massive tragedy
this has been the single biggest failure
of the union government in the last 73
years
and 73 years is since the independence
of india
so we can see the political impact the
political impact of modi's popularity
being eroded
probably for the first time as people
dies people realize that privilege
no longer protects you prime minister
modi was elected on
a massive majority in 2014 and he
repeated that in 2019.
he came in on a very business-friendly
platform and he has made some
considerable
reforms in india like a momentous
decision in 2016 to demonetise part of
the currency and basically
ban 86 of the currency overnight
and it didn't seem to affect his
popularity at all
so he's used to being the leader of the
country that that talks to people about
really big picture issues and and almost
on um on a religious level so i think he
thought he could float above
covid but the fact that no family in
india
has been untouched by this epidemic
everybody knows somebody who's
who's sick or who's died
[Music]
you know there's no way that the
government can hide from the impact of
this virus and as one analyst said to us
you can explain away bad gdp numbers but
you can't explain away
a dead family member you know that's not
something
that the government is going to be able
to cover up
it's unclear yet though whether his
support
has really been dented in the long term
elections are still you know years away
so it's really yet to be seen if this is
a turning point in
modi's support in his political
narrative
whether he can come back from this
[Music]
b point 1.617 the variant of the novel
corona virus
per sequence in india is far spreading
across the world
if indians are not vaccinated quickly
if india doesn't do everything to
contain its spread quickly enough
the risk is that more and more of these
mutations
could threaten not just the health and
livelihoods of the rest of the world
but also immense economic supply chains
india contributes more than eight
percent to global growth
but if you integrate what india does
into the systems of the world
into large banks into large
pharmaceutical companies most of the
seafaring ships which haul
cargo from one country to the other most
of these ships are manned by indians
what will happen to the supply chains
around the world if indians are unable
to get up
get out of their beds go to work be
healthy
think be on their feet enable that
business continues as usual
[Music]
as india's power and stature has grown
over the years
as it has taken on more and more
leadership roles
on the global stage world powers in
particular
the us is very reliant on india as
providing a kind of buffer against the
rise of china
in particular in in the asian region
it's really important that as a
democratic country
on the border with china india maintains
a strong global role and if it's
unable to get this pandemic under
control if it's unable
to boost its health infrastructure
enough to create
a stable environment and therefore allow
its economy to recover
from from the lockdowns then that global
stature that india has
will be under threat it's a lesson not
just for policymakers in india it's a
it's a lesson for leaders everywhere
about the areas of policy making that
need
focus about what could go wrong with
just one single decision
that a tiny virus unseen by the naked
eye
can take down strong men all over the
world if they're not careful
[Music]
[Music]
you